[Music]
you love The Originals lavish sets great
songs and dark sense of humor and you've
also seen the Tim Burton
version but when the people who made
Paddington have a new project you sit
down and enjoy some cozy British Whimsy
all right now cut the snark and feel
something other than smug for 90 minutes
is that so hard F Wonka
in a world where candy gets you turned
an Incredible Edible one plug will have
the fiends re up with that Wonka pack
just poing in and everything becomes a
Broadway show but when he moves against
a cartel who cooks the books at the cut
house under the church there were two
sets of books they've been watering down
their chocolate young won will try to
stay one step ahead of the shooters and
give shorty points on the package to
show him how the game is played we'll
split the profits and pay off Mr scrubb
it in no time yeah I have been
rewatching the wire why do you
ask forget everything you know about
willly Wonka especially the stuff that
made him interesting you see back in the
day he was just a naive little sweetie
well that all seems to be in order
really like clinically dumb you can't
read can you who was born with the most
tragic case of about to be dead mom in
cinema history I'll be right there
beside you promise I think you promise
you know sometimes it's best to leave an
icon's Origins a mystery especially if
you're Timothy shalam I'm getting daily
to the next Slim
Shady like like statistics statistics
statistics also suffering the lower
class he doesn't like it when people say
get ready for a film that proves Even in
our fantasies we can't imagine an
affordable City you have incurred a few
extras during the course of your
residency where the battle between nice
candy salesman and mean candy salesman
takes a backseat to the war between
ownership and the proletariat I gave her
a handful of sovereigns and had her
escorted from my property and sure
knowing that the hero becomes a cynical
Factory boss who keeps a staff of slaves
might tweak the final message a bit but
that's the sequels problem look look
tiny H GR in a
jetpack Cinema you've seen Timmy have
his way with sweets before now watch him
make all sorts of delicious candy of
disgusting ingredients that's the
hoverfly it's broken out of its cocoon
it's flapping its wings salted with the
Bittersweet tears of Russian clown I
require the milk of a giraffe that seems
about as sick to put in your body as the
morbius g- fuel powder take heat eat
more than three and you'll end up like a
gorilla if you thought the chocolate was
weird you're going to hate what happens
next it appears that the chocolates have
been poisoned nevertheless Wonka still
becomes the toast of U where does this
take place again the weather is Norway
the signs are German the names are
French and everyone's speaking English
one chocolate here moved on for the
usual fee hey I guys from New York we
can't even settle on a continent welcome
boys follow along on Wonka's Epic Quest
to escape dead slavery alongside a team
of trafficed Migrant workers they got
all of you too did they I'm afraid so
and yet another stealth musical filled
with way more songs than advertised but
if you don't like that genre fear not
because you won't remember the song
anyway as Timmy puts his one octave
range to work in non Bops like Words
that rhyme with
noodle
scood describing what we're doing scrub
scrub turn the giant handle scrub scrub
and U come on I just watched it should
me remember one more the crap is there a
song about chocolate there's
chocolate and there's chocolate
chocolate bushes chocolate trees you
never had cholate like this huh lucky
guess all I remember is his version of
tiny
horse
away
tin so give yourself over to one of the
year's ziest concoctions I don't have a
bunk on the
head with a little something for
everyone he means we're going to fart
them out of our that puts a
fresh spin on some classic IP but still
has to hit the lead mandated number of
references wait a minute what's all that
small CR there at the bottom a lifetime
supply of
chocolate not bad strike that scratch
that reverse we don't like our
imagination too pure God forbid we try
something original oh dear I've just
been a little bit sick in my mouth
starring D me by your name Roman noodles
oh is Olivia Comm then in it my pet
hired gooner Creep Show three Twix Mafia
orange man bad Jim Carter of Mars a dank
candy sketch show the Great British
baking shop Law and Order Eminem Mr
cocoa bean wonka
wonka and the mom to every British
Children's Fantasy
character chocolate salty brwl
hang on if the opening musical number
was only happening in Willy's
imagination how can we trust anything
else that we see he froze to death on
that park bench
huh Autobots it's trailer
time sometimes my genius is it's almost
frightening I'm from waterl where the
vampires hang out poor little bug on the
wall ding Jing no one to love him at all
ding
Jing